I know you don't remember me dear maybe
do you know any the hard you don't need
this for a living
do you did what was i funny yeah five or
six years ago it was had to be more than
that because it was because after lost
after New York New York I worked in
Harrah's and at the Venetian and that
was a while ago so it could have been
nine no wasn't it was a while ago well a
while is not specific it'd that comes in
that says do you know me say I'm one of
the greatest people you've ever met
really don't lie am I gonna know the kid
no nobody knows why is the kid he works
whose identity work so this is
interesting because I've been listening
you know you have to listen to the news
because it's and everybody says it's
okay because to like because they're not
under oath so all my life I've been
telling the truth and I haven't been
under oath and I shouldn't have been
because it's okay to lie right so I know
you and I'm so happy and I was wondering
how you've been because I'm not under
oath right so you can say why so just
tell me when I'm under oath and then I
will tell you the truth right but
otherwise I will literally it doesn't
matter doesn't it made a hit movie and
you were great I'm just saying you were
great are you under oath
you were great their industry to most
people if I've ever done interviews for
if I didn't tell my private remember
than if they were important yeah you
would remember yeah okay see rich he was
fighting with one of our staffers about
how well-known he was before he ran and
then he specifically brought up he was
like you know rita rudner's who's coming
who's coming into new money he goes she
was in my movie I said she was in a
movie and great that's all I say right
probably not probably not you know the
truth you do look familiar
[Laughter]
no but I do like you immediately you
smell great thank you very much it's a
combination I've come I created my own
combination of sense mm-hmm and it's
lime and basil with a nectarine honey
chaser and I smell a little like a
marinade but I don't care yes I just
like that it's a I love to like do you
know Joe Malone it's under oath I do
know Jo Malone candles you know I know
her because Sharon Osbourne likes for
candles I'm a sign up to the Osborn
sense but you can mix them and create
your own unique way right so I'm so glad
you enjoyed my whiff of nectarine and
honey and lime basil amazing thank you
very much yeah I do
now you under it yes you are you're
still doing gigs you I've been a fan of
yours yeah you are I mean for a long
time now and I know I don't get very
often though because I say I don't
gamble and I worked in Vegas for 25
years so I'm good
so I don't have to do what I don't like
to do so I do what I like to do great
every time I went on you poster you two
great poster which was you kind of
laying with your hands on me used to be
a dancer on Broadway you know that
potato yeah so I still stretch all the
time and my husband says stop it but I
don't listen to him because it's not
under oath and I just want to do what I
want to do
because I can't sleep seeing out too
much information women we share I do I'd
like to know that I wanna know rita
rudner's life is like I do I have to
stretch but um so I sound fat guy
Michael's what should I see on Broadway
tonight because I came here to visit to
see you thank you and and to visit all
of my friends because I haven't seen
them before I go to Sarasota so what
should I see tonight what's a good show
lame is is it not anymore is it
no Book of Mormon you know what I hear
they're selling lap seats now where I
can sit on I'm not only a hundred and
fifty dollars you know what
and it was funny when we interviewed you
and now people know read a runner in the
wedding dress or the gown or whatever
the gal she did all the crafty
one-nighters that we all did like a
Jerry Stanley gay time I ever made $25
Freddy's and and Penny arcade's I did
the place where they had the barrels of
peanuts yeah I threw the peanuts at ya
and ever end the chicken fights in the
parking lot yeah but I love that cool
would you do well in those cases you're
so clean and you're soft-spoken I'd say
you know what I think as long as you're
honest and you're under oath and when
you do comedy people are gonna go with
you if you try to be something you're
not
then I think you're in trouble you try
to act straight but I know I always give
myself away when I sit on my keys I come
it's just that's what my problem with
all these talent shows on television now
and the people are so that the people on
the voice I mean come on they've got
great voices yes and every single one of
them is terrific but when you don't come
through the ranks you don't develop who
you are so all of a sudden if you go
okay you won now your start isn't kind
of work and then they disappear but you
got I think you got to put in the
legwork don't you the gig work or it all
can come together and I enjoyed it did
you enjoy it I listen I had some of the
best times in my life doing those
one-nighters and going to Florida and do
the comic strip down there and doing in
fact unfriendly because I do theaters
and I
did a really nice theater in California
but I'm always afraid to try new
material in the theaters because there's
over a thousand people there so when I
try new material I love to go to clubs
I'm doing a club I'm doing a club here I
have to mention it 54 below
July 11th and 12th where's that it's on
54th Street below 54 54 and they mostly
do music excite be the only comedy gig
there cuz
but last year before last and it was
really fun and I get to visit all my
friends you read a runner you can work
wherever you want oh well that's very
nice of you thank you but I love to do
little intimate places because I'm freer
to try things and to talk to people and
I'm in Sarasota I leave tomorrow and I'm
doing a really nice Club there and then
I did I just did a special that's gonna
be on and I don't know how to get it
because I'm so old but it's gonna be on
on-demand so I guess you have to demand
it and then he's on 43 is not old that's
not under oath you are how many tonight
shows did you do with class you know a
lot of lot with Johnny Carson a lot with
him yeah he was very nice to me what
five years to get on the show because
Jim McCauley didn't like me and said
Johnny would hate me and I gave up I
just said you know I can live my life
without doing the Tonight Show it's fine
I would love to do it but I can't make
this guy I can't make you love me if you
don't
speaking as Bonnie Raitt so finally one
day this is in my cuz I'm writing an
autobiography to this one rod biography
and I can say that like that even though
I haven't been drinking Alex Friedman
who is Budd Friedman's wife
I'm Jim McCauley they were all sitting
together and every time I would get on
stage Jim McCauley would get up and
leave he would say I just don't even
want to see this girl oh she's on I'm
gonna get up and leave so he was sitting
with Alex Friedman and Alex said why
don't you watch her she's funny and made
Jim McAuley sit down and he watched me
and he said came over and he said okay I
have a few adjustments and then I think
maybe you're ready for the show so he
said this is my favorite thing anyone
ever
said have you watched Mary Lou Retton
because this was a long time ago and I
said yes she's a gymnast he said you
should watch her timing she's a gymnast
she said yeah but she's got good timing
I said I know she doesn't fall off the
beam but I have you noticed I'm a
comedian and he said well I want you to
put the first joke in the end the end
joking I said look I'll try whatever you
want to do he said meet me at the comedy
magic club the next night so I met him
at the comedy magic club in Hermosa
Beach and I did what he said and it was
terrible because he messed up what I've
been working right and I wasn't funny at
all nice and I'll go I'm not gonna be on
the show and then he came over he said
okay you're right it was better the
other way and then he put me on the show
and then Johnny liked me and then I was
on I don't know 15 times or so how
nerve-wracking is that though when
you've already been told Johnny's gonna
hate you and then you gotta go on and do
it oh it's horrendous especially because
I didn't get on the first couple times
they ran out of time oh yeah and then
Johnny said let's do a show called the
bump show because I've got three
comedians who can't get on and every
time they come they get bumped so I was
on a show called the bump show who you
are with Daryl savate and Rick Scheibner
and it was the three of us and we all
got to sit on the couch and talk to him
and from then on it was good and he
liked me it was really nice to me but
you Mason like I knew a guy that did
Carson fourteen or fifteen times one of
the funniest comics that David's a such
a great writer and he did caution 14
times but then where did he go like
you're going where did David go I wish
David liked the road better than he
liked anything because he had an active
life on the road yeah yeah I think you
all know what I mean
why don't I don't know David did he buy
a plane but you know we should around
and talk comics I'm gonna say names and
some of the biggest comics you know and
talk about how you are one of the best
joke writers in the business oh that's
very nice I know I know I always keep
trying and I get very excited still
after all these years that when I can
think of a new joke that's I have my
little my little thing here that I try
not to lose where I write down silly
things all the time but the thing is you
can never figure out what's funny unless
you say it to an audience I can't say
anything to my husband
or my daughter or my friends I can't
late you know put the pressure on them
cuz you go is this I used to do that
when I was just starting but the
audience is your your guide because no
audience gets together before a show and
says let's not laugh at that it's a
spontaneous organic response that
they're gonna have it's it's funny
they're gonna laugh and they tell me so
I love that I love my American Idol is
so much bigger than last comic because
musicians can practice at home
exactly okay singer can practice with a
comic cannot stand in front of the
mirror unless I'm a serving you can't
just do comedy without an audience and
not gonna you're gonna die so many times
even when I have to do like that if I'm
doing a television show and they go you
know you do a sound check and a lighting
check and everything and I said I'm not
gonna do my act because I can't stand it
I'm gonna say jokes there's nobody in
the audience know how awful is that when
they want you to do it to nobody but the
camera people just to get your million
no I can't do it I just do one two three
five six seven and and to say things
because it's just - it's debilitating
don't you admire I admire people though
there are people who could actually
literally cuz sometimes I put your stuff
in a prompter and they'll have you do it
and though and people who can actually
just do their act to an empty room and
go along with the program I kind of
admire their ability to do it like that
they don't it doesn't bother them I
can't I get too self-conscious I'm like
are they dancing without a partner you
know you're just doing half of it and
then the other half isn't there so it
doesn't work yeah it feels around with
one or two but I just pretend I'm doing
it to the cameraman or something you
know I remember the first season last
comic you had to perform in front of two
people it was ridiculous it was you know
a lot of us yeah Ross and but and I said
look at you after this I'll be some of
my CDs in the lobby to try to break it
up but you don't care you're just
[ __ ] mumbling you know what I'm
saying
in front I don't know maybe I'm not
making sense here no I know it's you I
don't care I just talk into a mic it
doesn't matter you do a bit you do I
care I don't like to do it I find it
embarrassing I've never been able to do
I just get to self car it's not that I
think I'm too cool for I'm just too
self-conscious I don't know I don't have
any timing because I take my timing from
the audience and I just don't have
there's no flow they do that on
America's Got Talent like the first
round you get to do it in the theater
and then everybody laughs and it's all
wonderful and then if you make it past
that the second round you just have to
do it for the table of judges just three
people oh my gosh that's like when you
have to go in and read something for
executives oh it's just awful like for
an acting audition or something yeah
yeah and they just sit there in the dark
and it's just I don't you know cuz I
don't do a lot of acting because first
of all I don't like acting and second of
all I don't I don't like driving into
Los Angeles because it's just too much
traffic and it makes me sick but I have
to sit there to get there at like 2:00
o'clock you have to start at 9:00
o'clock when because I have a beach
house and I live at the beach a lot of
the time and they give me these parts
because when you're an older woman as I
am they really don't have a slot so
every time they send me some sighs I
just got some sides and they said would
you like to be a grandma zombie or
something you know on the SyFy channel I
said no thank I'd rather walk on the
beach with my husband and my dog and
then they'd let's say I had a part for a
woman who couldn't find her teeth an old
woman they kept my dream in the world
they sent me one for oh yeah that's nice
I said I'm not gonna be in traffic for
any of those parts so ugly just one in
the world they called her that called me
yeah this is the ugliest woman in the
world it was a show with Greg Kinnear I
remember and they said people can't even
look at you it was in the script you
know as appealing as this sounds I'm
gonna have to tell are you uncomfortable
I think you know I like doing something
I've done movies that Martin at my
husband Martin Bergman we wrote and we
have a movie on iTunes called thanks
that was on Showtime and that did well
on Showtime and then we did we wrote an
older movie called Peters friends that I
was in and another movie called weakened
in the country with Dudley Moore and
Richard Lewis but when I can write it
and I can have some input in it it makes
it good what we do now we're doing plays
and
Martin and I've written our third play
and we're doing that at a little
Playhouse in the our beach house because
it's fun so I'm happy that I can do
things that are fun you just kinda pick
and choose what you want to do yeah will
you Frank I mean I knew you were on tour
with Dennis Miller I wanted a lot a lot
yeah he would ha he was right yeah he
was he was a brilliant writer and stuff
but were you like from do you ever work
with like a Pryor or did you know Pryor
no that was before me I work a lot with
Brad Garrett now he said nicest guy in
the world
this club in Vegas is he makes me laugh
constantly nice he is so sweet and I
worked a lot with Louie Anderson and
Roberto Klein and those are the people I
work with on the road a lot and Dennis
and I used to work a lot but now he
works with Bill O'Reilly so that's great
great comedy tour yeah you know I don't
know he just got more a little more
conservative I was he I guess he I guess
he was more liberal back then yeah now
he's like a political pundit yeah you
know I mean it's what it does I don't
know what changed him I don't know I
still I'm sure he's still a very nice
guy I haven't talked to him recently
um how is this Oliver I think Robert
Klein is so underrated we've had him on
show I leave my favorite people in fact
yes in fact I have questions for him
because I have something that we might
ask him to do that's going to be
exciting but I have to talk to him I
called him by accident the other day I
was walking my dog
and I pressed the wrong button cuz the
Sun was in my eyes and he answered and
he said Rita why are you calling me
because it cannot read a writer and I
said who is this I don't know I do
anyway so he's just the nicest funniest
guy I love did you ever work with Brian
David Brenner a lot I love David Brenner
yes I know he was another guy I just
couldn't stop laughing whenever I was
with him he was terrific you know course
if I didn't I never met Johnny Carson I
heard that he was people said he was
cold he could be very distant shy was he
shy yeah he was um he would always come
into the makeup room and say hello to me
and say how you know ask me how my day
was but that was like the third or
fourth time I
was on it took him a while to warm up so
and I think I mean I think is the same
look David Letterman when your job is
talking to people every day for years
and years and years it's hard you know I
just did a gig with Oprah because again
I do I'm very lucky and it was a cruise
to Alaska and they asked Oprah asked me
to do be the comedian on this cruise to
Alaska which was for her magazine and
you know she she's not the most
accessible person but you have to
realize that people just hound her for
her whole life so I understand why those
people have to be protected to a certain
degree
wait so you you you hung out with her on
the cruise again no I did you get to
meet her I met her before cuz I've been
on her show okay but it wasn't really I
went to her seminar and it was really
good she did like two big talks and then
I did my show and but I didn't I didn't
actually hang out with her because again
there how many people on the ship and
then what's she gonna do say hello to
everybody you know are those see you
probably never before but again I don't
know if you remember me if you run a
show Church you would I mean although
sometimes yeah have you ever thought
someone's gonna recognize you or
remember you and they didn't that's
humiliating
it's in my act yes I was at a Starbucks
once and somebody said I don't want to
insult you but you look a lot like Rita
Rudner
and that was when you did you meet
President Obama you performed for him
right yes and I did meet him but okay
this you want to hear the story I would
love to okay this is a bit story so they
asked me to do I'm a friend of Harry
Reid's and I did a lot for Harry Reid
when I was in Las Vegas and Harry Reid
called me up and said would you know I'm
doing for Obama's coming in for a
fundraiser for me and it was going to be
at Caesar's Palace would you host it and
it was me and Sheryl Crow and Bette
Midler and it was you know
it's gonna be scary because I'm not
known for political material but I'm
gonna try cuz I always like to try and
it was a special occasion and my
daughter at the time was I guess 7 so I
said I would love my daughter to meet
President Obama and they said you know
no problem
and we went in and they said okay it's
time to you and Cheryl and bet will come
meet President Obama and I said what
about my daughter Molly and they said
she hasn't been vetted and I said well
um she's seven you know something I
don't know you know and they said
there's no way that we can have somebody
who isn't vetted meet President Obama
and I said well I don't think there's
any way that I can host the show you
know because wow that's really
unacceptable I mean little daughter
sitting there and I was all dressed up
and so they said well we'll have to
we'll have to have some the president of
the SIS of the security agency come talk
to you so they had him come talk to me
and they said it's just a rule that we
can't do that and I said it's just a
rule that I can't go on today I mean I
was so angry so finally they had the
head of a head of head security come
down and he said what's the problem and
I said well everybody is telling me that
my seven-year-old daughter can't say
hello to President Obama and they said
that's ridiculous bring her in just that
quickly yeah yeah so we went in and he
was absolutely charming and he said um
you know very nice to meet you Molly I
have two daughters about your age you
should come and play at the White House
and you know and you know it worked but
I had to go through that so I was a
little bit taken aback and then Molly
said mommy when are we gonna go to the
White House so I can play and I said
he's a politician and he says things
like
no [ __ ] until you want you to white
house that's true and he said we have a
new playground that we built out of
recycled tires you can come and play
were you really gonna back out of the
gig at that absolutely I mean that I
just thought that was you bet you at
some point you got to stand up and say
this is ridiculous that my
seven-year-old daughter hasn't been
vetted so what do you think was the
biggest gig that you've ever done
because that's a pretty that's a pretty
big give me with that line up with that
with with President Obama there that it
has to be among the biggest and this
doesn't care because I could do it I had
a line where Harry Reid came up and did
a speech and then he introduced
President Obama and then President Obama
did his speech and then they introduced
me and I said I never thought my two
opening acts would be President Obama
and Senator Harry Reid oh that's when
the show started after the speech yeah
oh that's nice what club do you work out
of in New York the impoverished I
started at the improv because I used to
go I was in Annie on Broadway and I used
to go walk from Annie to Percy did you
yell triple in which was across the
street and then there was the piano bar
and then I'd go to the improv and after
a while silver again people don't some
you know people just some people don't
like you
silver Friedman who ran that Club you
remember I don't know yes yes yes they
liked me and she said you're gonna have
to change everything about yourself
you're gonna have to change your voice
your voice isn't good for comedy and you
don't have any timing I said maybe I
should meet Mary Lou Retton IRA and so I
used to get on at 2:00 in the morning
all the time me and Donna oh I forget
her last name she's a really good singer
on Broadway she's under studying on
Hello Dolly but anyway we would always
be on it - good morning and Bill Maher
said you know I've just gotten a gig
hosting at catch a rising star and this
is ridiculous that they don't put you on
till 2:00 in the morning and I will put
you on a ket rising star
so I said okay and I started going over
to catch and he started putting me on
the silver silver didn't pass Eddie
Murphy either
really
you said I don't see it a comic-strip
yes any became a commissar well I went
over to catch and started getting on and
then working the comic strip in the
Comedy Cellar yeah those places but she
just uh she was a tough cookie did you
ever did you ever get in with her or no
I never saw her again no I did anyone
know whatever happened I do I'm not I
don't know I think she moved out to LA
and is living with her daughter Zoey
okay I think who can say you were on
Broadway before you're doing comedy oh
yeah for ten years right yeah so what
when you start did you think that
Broadway was drying up and you should go
over to comedy was it just like this
thing relates to me more like how do you
make that transition okay I was reading
an article because I have very little I
don't have a great education and I
decided I had to educate myself so I'd
read the New York Times every day
because I moved to New York when I was
fifteen and started your high school
dropout no I graduated but I did a
skipped 11th grade and I just did and I
did 12th and courses in the summer and I
still I want to be a dancer why do I
want to sit for so I was reading an
article about soft soap in the New York
Times and it said this is a new product
on the market when you introduce a new
product you can either introduce a bar
soap and then you're going to be in
competition with every bar soap that's
already there or you can introduce a new
way to experience soap and that was the
liquid soap that had just you know
started and I said well I can either be
a dancer and there and singer and
actress and they're resilient of them or
I can be a comedian and I really only
know two female comedians Joan Rivers
and Phyllis Diller that were i evident
to me at the time and neither one of
them were doing an act that I could even
though I met both of them later in their
lives and they were wonderful women and
I admired both of them tremendously
they were both doing very aggressive
styles of comedy and I wanted to do
something that was more laid-back and
hadn't been done before so I said well I
could be like a liquid soap
and so I started doing that and then I
found out that I love I love that it was
a dormant love that I had for it I
didn't well you know I remember when I
was a kid sneaking out cuz I didn't have
a TV in my room my parents wouldn't let
me and watching Johnny Carson's
monologue a lot and I could always
remember everything that he said the
next day but I just never knew I would
ever be a comedian ever I was watching
last night I was watching some random
Johnny Carson clip of 1974 and he's just
bombing it was so great vomit when you
can bomb like that knowledge it it's
good I should come home from school and
fourth a fourth grade I had wishing to
Vaughn meter every day that's what you
did in your final year in school yeah of
the Kennedys were spot on and this was
the biggest comic at the time the
biggest and then when they got
assassinated no one would have done and
I just say one of shitty gigs I think I
know who he is move on yeah and then
there's all of a sudden have that dry
out but to have your gig and it could
there's no way to wouldn't he just be
she says Kennedy he would do is like his
speeches he was just doing he was doing
he album was one of them the first
family the day after Kennedy got shot
Lenny Bruce went on stage he goes well
there's one meters career because you
can do other stuff you really have just
pushed it all into that one basket
there's no comeback there was a comedian
who used to do Ronald Reagan impressions
when that was but maybe him too but I
remember Jim Morris yeah and then when
he left they would still call for it it
does dry if you can't do anyone else it
does because the the I guess the need
for it is just not that because don't
cares if you do Bush now or climb right
so I'll trumpet somebody like rich
little will work forever but he's doing
everybody exactly he's doing you know
yeah I guess he still works